It's been more than 20 years since
this hilarious sports comedy came
out. Even though critics of its day didn’t
love it, “The Replacements” has been a movie
classic for many. Here's what members of
the cast have been up to in the time since.
Beloved veteran actor Keanu Reeves brought
the world's most talented barnacle scraper,
quarterback Shane Falco, to
life in "The Replacements."
After his turn as the downtrodden
former QB, Keanu Reeves promptly
disappeared and was never heard from again.
Oh, wait, that didn't happen. In reality,
Reeves has spent the two decades since
"The Replacements" came out becoming one
of the biggest movie stars in modern cinema, and
starring in more blockbusters than we can count.
The year after “The Replacements,” he
starred as lovable loser Conor O'Neill
in the heartstring-tugging "Hardball." In 2003,
he reprised his role as Neo for not one but two
sequels to "The Matrix," before playing the
title character in 2005's "Constantine."
He played undercover cop Bob Arctor
in 2006's drug-fueled, dystopian,
rotoscoped Philip K. Dick adaptation "A
Scanner Darkly." Two years later took
on the role of Klaatu in the remake
of "The Day the Earth Stood Still."
Reeves made his directorial debut in 2013
with "Man of Tai Chi," in which he also
played Donaka Mark. A year later, he launched the
massively successful series of "John Wick" movies,
starring as the titular assassin
in three films so far. "John Wick:
Chapter 4" is, at the time of this
video’s release, currently filming.
Actor Gene Hackman took on the role of demanding
but understanding head coach of the Washington
Sentinels, Jimmy McGinty. Or, as Shane Falco
called him, "that old coach from the '80s.".
A year after "The Replacements," Hackman
appeared in the crime rom-com "Heartbreakers."
Alongside Sigourney Weaver, Jennifer Love
Hewitt, and Ray Liotta, he played William,
the unwitting mark of a marriage
con. In 2001 he starred as Royal,
the father of the eccentric titular family in Wes
Anderson's quirky comedy "The Royal Tenenbaums,"
co-starring Ben Stiller, Gwyneth
Paltrow, Owen Wilson, and Luke Wilson.
The same year, Hackman teamed with Owen
Wilson again for the war thriller "Behind
Enemy Lines," playing Navy admiral Leslie
Reigart. He was the commanding officer of
the USS Carl Vinson whose fighter pilot was
shot down on a routine reconnaissance mission.
In 2003, he starred alongside Dustin Hoffman,
Rachel Weisz, and John Cusack in the legal drama
"Runaway Jury," adapting a John Grisham novel.
In his final film role before retiring, Hackman
starred in the 2004 political comedy "Welcome to
Mooseport" with Ray Romano. He played former
United States president Monroe "Eagle" Cole,
who gets drawn into an increasingly silly
campaign to become mayor of a small town in Maine.
Head cheerleader Annabelle Farrell was
brought to life by actor Brooke Langton.
Not only is she an amazing on-field performer,
she's a huge football fan. Even if Shane’s entire
team turned against him, he would always
have one true believer on the sidelines.
Two years after appearing in "The
Replacements," Langton showed up in
many guest roles on popular TV shows like
"Weeds" in 2005 and "Monk" in 2006. Langton
reunited with "The Replacements" co-star Orlando
Jones for the B-horror movie "Primeval" in 2007,
playing a journalist who travels to Burundi to
try to capture a giant, man-eating crocodile.
Later that year, she joined the main cast
of NBC's crime drama "Life," playing the
role of Constance Griffiths. She’s the
attorney who proved the innocence of the
wrongly-convicted lead character Detective
Charlie Crews, played by Damian Lewis.
In the years since, Langton has appeared
in a few other popular series and films,
like “The Debt” in 2015. In 2018, she took on the
recurring role of Lieutenant Maddie Rawlings on
TNT's action-drama series "The Last Ship" for
five episodes, working alongside the rest of
the crew of the USS Nathan James to try to find
a cure for the pandemic that ravages the planet.
Actor Orlando Jones was a perfect choice
for the role of less-than-sure-handed wide
receiver Clifford Franklin. He might have had
some serious wheels and major breakaway speed
but he sure didn't have the mitts and dexterity
required to haul in a pass with any consistency.
Jones kept plenty busy following his turn as
Franklin. A few months after "The Replacements"
was released, he took on multiple roles in the
Faustian comedy remake of "Bedazzled." There,
Elizabeth Hurley plays the Devil, enticing Brendan
Frazer's hapless character to sell his soul.
The next year, Jones played community
college professor Harry Block
in the underrated sci-fi comedy "Evolution,"
fighting an alien invasion. A year later,
he appeared as the digital artificial
intelligence librarian Vox 114 in "The Time
Machine," a loose adaptation of the classic
H.G. Wells novel of the same name. In 2003,
Jones joined Gene Hackman as part
of the cast of "Runaway Jury."
In addition to his work in feature films, Jones
has enjoyed plenty of success on the small screen,
including his turn as Captain Frank
Irving on the supernatural procedural
"Sleepy Hollow." He also nabbed a recurring
role as Mr. Nancy, aka the tricker god Anansi,
on the popular Neil Gaiman series "American Gods."
Kicker Nigel Gruff, as played by actor Rhys Ifans,
isn't exactly what you'd call athletic — though
it's clear his liver gets a regular workout.
The former soccer striker is
more what you'd call "wiry."
Three months after the release of
"The Replacements," Ifans appeared
alongside another talented cast, taking on
the role of Adrian, one of the sons of Satan
in Adam Sandler's "Little Nicky."
In 2001, he took on the role of Iki,
a club owner who also deals in drugs and guns
in "The 51st State." The film starred Samuel
L. Jackson as a revolutionary drug chemist
and was alternately titled "Formula 51."
In 2010, Ifans had an iconic turn as Xenophilius
Lovegood, publisher of the Quibbler and father
to Luna Lovegood in "Harry Potter and the Deathly
Hallows: Part 1." Two years later, he played Dr.
Curt Connors, mentor to Peter Parker, played by
Andrew Garfield, and eventual reptilian villain
in "The Amazing Spider-Man." Ifans also enjoyed
a recurring role as Mycroft Holmes, brother to
Sherlock Holmes, played by Jonny Lee Miller, on
the modern American crime procedural "Elementary."
Actor Michael Jace portrayed defensive back
Earl Wilkinson, who went to prison for allegedly
beating up a cop — naturally he mixes well with
Danny Bateman. As such, Wilkinson wears a tinted
visor on his helmet and plays under the alias Ray
Smith. This is so no one’s aware that a convicted
felon has been released by the governor to
serve as a replacement player during the strike.
Jace is perhaps best known as Julien Lowe,
a uniformed police officer and member of the
main cast of "The Shield," FX's gritty crime
drama. He appeared in all 88 of the series'
episodes across its seven seasons, portraying a
cop enduring the inner conflict his homosexuality
brought about with his devout Christian
faith. Lead character Vic Mackey is aware
of Julien's sexual orientation and
blackmails him to keep a secret.
Jace's final credited role was recurring character
Terrell on the crime drama "Southland." In 2014,
according to CNN, Jace was arrested and charged
with homicide in the fatal shooting of his wife,
April Jace, having reportedly dialed 911 himself.
Michael Jace was convicted of second-degree murder
in May 2016, per ABC7, which reported the jury
deliberated for fewer than three hours before
reaching a guilty verdict. A month later, Jace
was sentenced to 40 years to life in prison.
He is currently incarcerated in California State
Prison and will be eligible for parole in 2039
according to the California Department
of Corrections and Rehabilitation.
If there's one thing for which
quarterback Shane Falco can be grateful,
it's that linebacker Danny Bateman,
played by Jon Favreau, is on his team.
This means that he's only on the receiving end
of his crushing tackles when Bateman forgets
that he's not supposed to hit players wearing
red jerseys in practice. Opposing QBs had better
look out, because he hits hard and fast, despite
having only played college football as a walk-on.
The year after "The Replacements" came out,
Favreau wrote and directed his first feature film,
"Made," in which he also starred. He appeared
alongside Vince Vaughn as a mediocre boxer who
gets involved in low-level organized crime. Two
years later, Favreau took on the role of Franklin
"Foggy" Nelson in the much-maligned,
Ben Affleck-starring Marvel Comics movie
"Daredevil." Of course, in 2008, he helped
launch the Marvel Cinematic Universe as
Harold "Happy" Hogan, Tony Stark's driver,
bodyguard and best friend in "Iron Man."
Favreau appeared in all three "Iron Man" solo
films — as well as directing the first two — in
addition to helping to mentor Peter Parker, Tom
Holland, in the MCU's two "Spider-Man" movies.
Favreau has continued to direct and produce,
helming the live-action remakes of Disney's
"The Jungle Book'' and "The Lion King." If all
of that wasn't enough, he is also the creator
and serves as showrunner of "The Mandalorian,"
the "Star Wars" streaming series on Disney+.
According to Coach Jimmy McGinty, tight
end Brian Murphy, played by David Denman,
would have been drafted in the first round if
he hadn't been born deaf. Despite living with
such a limitation, Brian manages to excel as a
member of the replacement Washington Sentinels.
“Look at it this way: he’ll never
be called offsides on an audible.”
Denman’s turn as Brian was his first
appearance in a feature-length film.
In 2001, he took on the role of Lance, the gay
bartender at the fictional Alaskan ski resort
of Bull Mountain in the snowboarding comedy
"Out Cold." Denman played bully Don Price,
who beats up protagonist Edward Bloom
in Tim Burton's 2003 fantasy film
"Big Fish." Denman's most recent film
role came in 2020's "Greenland," for
which he took on the character Ralph Vento,
who kidnaps John Garrity's son Nathan.
Denman has also enjoyed memorable small screen
roles, including appearing as Ed Brooks,
the adulterous love interest of Julia
Braverman-Graham. That was on the NBC
family dramedy series "Parenthood." He also
recently took on the role of Frank Sheehan,
ex-husband to the title character in the
acclaimed HBO limited series "Mare of Easttown."
Ace Yonamine took on the larger-than-life role
of "Jumbo" Fumiko, a member of the replacement
Washington Sentinels' offensive line. He's a
former sumo wrestler, which makes him an expert
at pushing people around. As Coach Jimmy McGinty
says, in the world of professional football,
that translates to pass blocking. Fumiko's also
the big hero of the bar fight, having sat on
Wilson's head, and his kiai becomes a popular
rallying cry among the team. Unfortunately,
he commits a holding penalty when Shane Falco
improbably runs the ball in for a touchdown on
the field goal attempt, during which Nigel Gruff
was nearly forced to blow the kick on purpose.
Yonamine's role in "The Replacements" is an
instance of art imitating life; prior to his
appearance in the movie — his feature film debut
— the Hawaiian born actor worked in Japan as a
sumo wrestler, according to Hawaiian outlet
Midweek. To date, Yonamine has only appeared
in two additional films, according to IMDb. In
2003, he appeared in "Lara Croft Tomb Raider:
The Cradle of Life." He was an imposing member
of the criminal organization Shay Ling, which was
hired by Dr. Jonathan Reiss to retrieve the map
to the mystical object. In 2005, Yonamine appeared
as a sumo wrestler in "Memoirs of a Geisha."
According to Midweek, he's continued acting
by appearing in commercials and works security
at the courthouse in Pearl City, Oahu, Hawaii.
Jamal Jackson, as played by actor Faizon Love,
is a bit of a hothead. He and brother Andre are
a formidable pair of guards that Coach Jimmy
McGinty recruits back into football after
they retire and become actual bodyguards.
After the bar fight that unites the team,
the brothers realize it's their job to protect
quarterback Shane Falco on and off the field,
so when the striking players harass quarterback
Shane Falco in the parking lot a second time,
Jamal pulls a gun and shoots
Eddie Martel's car multiple times.
A year after appearing in "The Replacements,"
Love showed up in various films, including
“Couples Retreat” with co-star Jon Favreau,
who also co-wrote the film. He took on the role
of Shane, the recently divorced guy with a wild,
20-something girlfriend. In 2003, he appeared
in the charming Will Ferrell Christmas comedy
"Elf" — also directed by Favreau — as Wanda. He’s
the manager of the Gimbels department store who
sends Buddy, played by Ferrell, into a frenzy
by announcing that Santa Claus would be coming.
In addition to finding steady work as a
character actor in films, Love also appeared
in nine episodes of Kevin Hart's BET reality
TV parody "Real Husbands of Hollywood." He
played a fictionalized version of himself in the
show's first, fifth, and sixth seasons. In 2018,
Love joined the cast of "Step Up: High Water"
— a drama series based on the popular "Step
Up" movies — as Al Baker. Love appeared in the
first two seasons that aired on YouTube Red.
"Step Up" was picked up for a third
season by premium cable network Starz.
Actor Michael Taliferro took on the role of Andre
Jackson, the larger brother to Jamal who is a bit
more level-headed, though just as protective
of Shane Falco once the team comes together.
In that memorable parking lot scene, Andre
reveals that he's pretty fond of the smell
of that wild yam that Annabelle Farrell
gave Shane to soothe his sore muscles.
“What’s that smell?”
“Wild yam.”
“Mmm. That’s nice.”
Following "The Replacements," Taliferro's
next film appearance came in the independent
crime drama "Blue Hill Avenue." He took on the
role of Simon, an adrenaline-fueled criminal who,
with his three friends, is one of the
biggest drug dealers in Boston. In 2002,
Taliferro appeared as inmate "Little Joe" in the
crime thriller "Half Past Dead," helping Steven
Seagal's FBI agent character rescue a kidnapped
Supreme Court justice on Alcatraz. For 2004's
dance film "You Got Served," he played Emerald.
He was the drug lord for whom lead characters
Elgin and David work in order to pay for the Lil
Saints to enter their street dancing battles.
Taliferro's final film role came as Brian Smith
in the crime musical "A Day in the Life," a film
that was released in 2009, a little more
than three years after his death in 2006.
As the Tampa Bay Times reported, he died on May 4
at the age of 44 after suffering a stroke
near his home in Los Angeles, California.
Troy Winbush brought to life pious running back
Walter Cochran. Cochran is one of the replacement
Washington Sentinels with some actual experience
playing professional football, though not much. He
played one game in the pros and blew out his knee,
pretty much ending his career — or so he thought.
When given a second chance at playing football, he
just wants to score one touchdown. Thankfully he
manages to do just that, though he blows out his
knee again in the process. Cochran notably makes
Shane Falco promise to finish what he started.
We assume he’s telling him to win the game.
One of Winbush's next feature film
roles came in the 2002 thriller
"John Q," in which he appeared
as expectant father Steve Smith.
He is one of the character John Archibald's
hostages. Denzel Washington’s role is of a
desperate father who seeks to get his son on
the recipient list for a heart transplant.
In the years since, Winbush has found
consistent work as an actor taking on
guest roles in various popular TV series.
He's appeared in shows ranging from police
procedurals like “NCIS” to dramas like
"Saving Grace.” He's also had a recurring
role as Officer Puchinski on the popular sitcom
"The Goldbergs." Winbush recently appeared in
Season 1 of "The Wilds" — the streaming drama
from Amazon Studios — as FBI Agent Dean Young.
Ugh, Eddie Martel, played by Brett
Cullen. Where to even start with this guy?
He's a prima donna, ending the final
game before the player's strike with
a giveaway slide instead of going for the win.
Martel's also an unrepentant jerk who has his
fellow striking players flip Shane Falco's
already-beat up truck in the parking lot.
In reality, we hope Cullen is a decent person
and we've got no reason to believe otherwise,
though he's played some other sketchy
characters in the years since.
Starting in 2005, he took on the
recurring role of Goodwin Stanhope,
one of the Others sent to infiltrate the group
of surviving passengers of Oceanic Flight 815
on "Lost." Cullen also appeared as the
creepy, adulterous congressman in 2012's
"The Dark Knight Rises," though that wouldn't
be his last role in a DC Comics Batman film.
Having seemingly perfected
playing an entitled jerk,
he took on the role of Thomas Wayne, the father
of the future Caped Crusader Bruce Wayne who's
also maybe-maybe-not the father of Arthur Fleck,
played by Joaquin Phoenix. He is, of course,
the Joker, in 2019 the 2019 film, "Joker."
Cullen also had a recurring role on "The
Blacklist" beginning in the finale episode
of Season 6. He also appeared in Season 3
of "True Detective" as the eventual
Arkansas Attorney General Gerald Kindt.
Veteran actor Jack Warden brought Washington
Sentinels owner Edward O'Neil to life.
He's an old-school kind of guy and he hilariously
yells at Eddie Martel from his luxury box.
He declares the cocky quarterback to be a
wimp, after his give-up slide at the end
of the final pre-strike game. Though
he uses a different word altogether
when courting Jimmy McGinty to be his
new head coach. In said negotiations,
he promises to give Coach McGinty full control of
the team. Spoiler alert, he breaks that promise.
After Martel tells McGinty that O'Neil will
fire him when Shane Falco shows up
during halftime of the final game,
the furious coach yells something that elaborates
on the troubled history between the two.
"It won't be the first time.”
"The Replacements" marked Warden's final
film appearance, as he retired from acting,
citing concerns of declining health. He
turned 80 the year the film came out. As
the BBC reported in 2006, Warden died at age
85 after weeks of poor health. His manager had
told the outlet that Warden had suffered from
heart and kidney problems prior to his death.
Check out one of our newest
videos right here! Plus,
even more Looper videos about your
favorite movies are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one.